if you've ever not gotten the deal or
you've ever not had someone believe in
you you've been doubted because of the
way you look how old you are how young
you are what gender you are where you're
born where you're not born the way you
dress the way you look the way you talk
then the question isn't whether that
bias is true cuz it may absolutely be
true but the question is what do we do
about it anyways and how can we confront
the other alternative reality that might
be true which is what if you're just not
good enough now what there was a lady
who made a post and she said I quit my
job to start doing this because my boss
didn't respect me because I was a woman
and so because of that um I quit my job
to start doing this and I had this
immediate thought in my head what
if you're just not good
enough that was the thought that came
through my mind when I read that message
and it got me fired up because the
amount of times in my life that I've
seen this victimized mentality hurt
people is far more than it has ever
helped and so the reason I want to talk
about this is because it applies to
employees it applies to business owners
and I have so many stories of this that
I want to drive through this and then I
want to drive to the two natural
conclusions that end up coming from
logic all right and so this is the same
thing as the kid who says hey um I
started this marketing agency and I've
you know I've got these services and I'm
trying to go to these business owners
and they're saying well they're not
buying for me because I'm a kid right
I'm too young right I had a a family
member who had a restaurant and he
opened it up in the wrong part of town
and he was like well my restaurant's not
working because people don't want to
come to this this side of the this side
of the neighborhood they have bias
against side this side of the
neighborhood and I'll give you another
one which was uh Jacob who was my
neighbor my little 15-year-old neighbor
from way back when when I walked in on
him trying to sell a wholesale deal and
he got off the phone and he'd been
trying to sell wholesale deals for you
know a month cuz he' read some stuff on
the internet watched some YouTube videos
and I was like so you know how's it
working he was and he was like well no
one's no one's really you know buying
yet and I could tell that on some level
it was because he thought that he was
too young and people aren't taking him
seriously so one of our portfolio
companies had two people who were in a
conflict all right so there was a white
guy and a black guy and they were peers
and they had to work together and they
didn't like each other and so finally we
had to be like y'all need to get along
figure it out and so the white guy sends
the black guy a song and it's his like
way of of trying to make amends and the
song was a a rap song and it had some
lyrics in it that offended the black guy
and he said you know this is not
racially sensitive blah blah blah blah
blah and he then asked for the white guy
to go through racial sensitivity
training and here's where this gets
interesting the black guy is married to
a a white girl and has mixed kids and
the white guy is married to a black girl
and has mixed kids do you think he
[__] needs racial sensitivity
training no he just doesn't like you for
the content of your character and so
there's a very significant possibility
that it might not be because you're too
young it might not be because you're
black it might not be because you're a
woman it might not be because you're a
republican it might not be because
you're a Democrat it might not be
because you're trans you just might not
be good enough and the thing is is that
even if you're right even if there is a
[__] bias because biases will exist
I'm not even going to deny that they
absolutely exist and they will always
exist and the reason they will always
exist is because this is how human
beings learn you learn and you create
judgments to to wish for a world that
doesn't create bias wishes for a world
where humans don't learn if you go and
you're a waitress and you serve a table
and it's all people with red faces and
those red faces leave you zero tip and
then you go to a table with green faces
and the green faces leave you a big tip
and then you do that again and again and
the red faces leave you lower tips then
the green faces and the green faces
leave you big tips what will you do you
will begin to expect that red faces
leave you no tip and green faces leave
you big tip now replace red and green
with tall white asian woman whatever the
point is is that people will learn and
as long as there are stereotypes that
exist because people do behave in a
certain way then people are going to
learn those things period but the thing
is is let's say you're a red face and
you do tip well and you hate the fact
that when you walk to a place they don't
treat you a certain way right and the
thing is is that biases exist everywhere
and I want to be clear here when I got
into the gym space I was young I was so
youngl looking that I knew no one took
me seriously and so I lied about being
the owner I lied so when people came in
I just said I'm the owner and IID worked
out a deal that I would I would
potentially earn in my ownership so I
had this whole backstory that I made up
in the beginning because I look so young
that no one would believe that I was the
one who owned the gym and so I'm saying
this because I I get it and to be fair I
look the way I look if I have a tank top
on like we moved into a very nice
Penthouse my neighbors immediately
complained about me he literally sent to
the the email to the front desk of the
building and said is what is this
Beverly Hillbillies who moved in next to
us I'm not kidding and so the thing is
is that I mean I thought it was [__]
hilarious I died I thought it was great
but the thing is is that what does that
mean he has a bias against people who
look like me right who who wear white
beaters and walk around like that on a
regular basis and he thinks
wow this guy I've had negative
experiences with people like him and so
the thing is is I have a friend from
college way back when black guy and he
hated that there was a stereotype that
black people don't tip he hated it and
so rather than try and say this is
unfair the world is unfair this bias
exists you know what he did he was
always really nice and and he always
over tipped that was what he did he over
tipped because the thing is is that
let's let's play out the scenarios you
bitching moan and you say you know what
this person didn't buy because I'm young
this person didn't buy because I'm a
woman this person didn't buy because of
whatever and the thing is is let's say
you you do some empirical study and you
prove it
right now what great you prove that you
have a disadvantage okay again now what
hey if you want to get around people who
are actually winning who look like you
who smell like you who talk like you and
are doing what you want to do I'd like
to invite you to the the school games
community at school.com games I take
calls in there I put content that's like
this and more personalized inside of
that community and I drop a huge amount
once a month an 8 Hour training on how
to actually take this stuff and win
anyways and so if that's interesting
school.com forgames see you in there the
thing is is that arguing for for proving
a bias is good for society bad for the
individual and as far as we're concerned
this is a single player game life and so
we've got to go through it with the
assumption that nothing's going to
change and what are we going to do about
it anyways because no one gets better by
feeling sorry for themselves no single
person has ever gotten better by proving
that they were the victim of something
ever and so whether you're an employee
and you're getting you feel like you're
getting passed up for the promotion and
the amount of times that we get this too
like I'm a business owner we have a lot
of businesses we have a lot of employees
and the thing is is that if someone gets
passed up maybe there is a bias because
biases will always exist but the only
thing you can do is be better than the
bias you have to be better than the bias
you have to be so [__] good that you
have to be you have to overcompensate he
didn't tip normally he tipped more than
normal so that he could be one one light
on the bad dots that he felt that the
people who had served him in the past
had experienced and so to give you a the
a story that I had with Jacob so he was
the young kid he sounded like a child on
the phone and the reason they weren't
buying the deals from him was because he
sounded like a [__] child on the
phone and the thing is is that what if
they're right and I think this is where
people get even more offended it's like
what if the bias that you have what if
what if what if the bias that You'
you've experienced against what if it's
true and this is where people get what
if I do act like a
hillbilly right what if I do act what if
what if I did act immature because I was
young now
what and so the thing is is that one if
you prove that there's a bias again so
what now you've proven that there's a
bias your life's not any
better version two what if they're right
so one you're proving that there's a
bias and you don't act that way the next
the next vein of thinking is what if
what if they're right about it what if
you just you are exactly The Stereotype
what if I am immature what if I don't
show up on time what if I am emotional
because I'm because I act like a child
because I haven't matured yet because I
haven't enough experience in life now
what if I'm not consistent because I
haven't learned that skill yet which
most more young people have that than
old people old people are notoriously
consistent they love their routines
eight how many 80 year olds do you know
who don't have routines hard to not have
one when you're 80
right you have to break the stereotype
of old people by by being spontaneous
right and so the thing is is like these
stereotype exist because biases exist
because we're going to always learn
we're always going to make judgments but
it comes down to whether your restaurant
on the wrong side of the street whether
you have a red face or a green face or
you're short and girls girls don't like
short guys okay if you believe the bias
then you make it true you make it real
you give it more power rather than less
and so I look like this I look probably
in terms of like my look I probably look
right leaning I probably look a little
bit hillbilly is if I take if I put the
wife beater on then I definitely look
Dumber in general I mean when I had my
gym people I had many people asked me if
I was literate but as soon as I opened
my mouth it became apparent that I was
educated and so the thing is and here's
here's my silver lining for this is that
if you have a bias you actually have the
opportunity to stand out even more by
being against it if if a green face tips
more than a red like than a just tips a
lot then it's like well I expected a
green face to tip more but if a red face
tips a lot you're like whoa I know
noticed that if a guy in a suit sounds
literate and sounds
educated you're not really surprised
there because it's what you
expected but if a jack guy and a beater
who looks like a hick and maybe had
doesn't have hillbilly views of the
world isn't a racist might have a more
articulate way of expressing things then
all of a sudden you pause and that
person becomes more interesting they
start to break the bias they start to be
better than the bias you start to create
a category that's separate for that
individual so there are many red faces
but this one is John and John's cool
John tips well the thing is is that I
think all of us have the opportunity to
be John or Sarah who who is a redface
who there are there are biases that
exist but we can be better than the bias
and I love this I love this quote from
from Andy forcella it's so good I
[__] wish it were
mine he said personal Excellence is the
ultimate rebellion and I just [__]
love that
and so the question is always what are
you going to do about it proving that it
exists does nothing you just prove that
there's you have a disadvantage okay we
all have disadvantages in some way to
some person like if I go into a place
that has had a lot of guys in flannels
who said racist things to them as soon
as I walk in the room there's going to
be a bias against me they're not going
to like me by right at the onset and so
what can I do you can play into the bias
I can complain CL that there's a bias or
I can overcompensate I can tip more than
anyone normally does I can be more kind
more understanding more literate I can
work harder and so I'm going to wrap
this to to to Jacob because I I'll tell
you the story obviously I said listen I
think you suck at sales I think it has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
young and so you got to learn and he's
like well how do I learn and I like well
you got to do more than everybody else
and I'm going to give you the advice
that I told him and I would say that he
says has changed his life and so I will
share it with you and this goes for the
employees this also goes for the
business owners it work works for
everyone which is I said volume negates
luck I said if you want to be the best
find the best guy in my company so I got
him an interview I said I will not get
you the job I said I can get you an
interview because the guy who's going to
be hiring you I was like it's up to him
and he's got 10 other guys he's been
interviewing and so he decided to give
him the give him a shot right that's I
mean at gym launch in sales like getting
a job is getting a shot that's all it is
you still got to work your leads you
still got to go generate you got to
generate sales and so he got on the
phones and I said go find the best guy
look at what he does and do twice as
much because you have to do twice as
much cuz he's better than you you can't
do as much as the best guy cuz he's
always just going to get ahead you have
to do what he's doing and another full
day's work so that you can start
catching up and so he started doing
twice as much as what the best guy was
doing and so over time he became the
best guy on the outbound team and then
he became and then he moved up to the
middle sales team and became the best
guy on the qualification team which is
the second the second highest level of
sales guys that we have and then from
there being the best guy and here's the
thing here's the the [__] thing
because he was so young he's 18 years
old 18 years old all the guys who were
my closers were all men with families
like they were professionals it was a
strong team it still is a strong team
and the sales manager a man with a
family said he he was hesitant he had a
bias against him because he was young he
said listen I I'm not going to just let
you on the team now he had objectively
had better stats as a Setter and anybody
who had been 30 years old or the family
would have absolutely gotten put on The
Closer team but he said I want you to go
self-generate end to end click to close
you go find someone in the [__] world
bring them all the way and close them
yourself before I let you on the closing
team he had never asked anyone else to
do that and so he did after he did one
he was like I need you to do another one
to make sure it wasn't a fluke so he did
another one and he said you know what
just because I want the team to be
really sure because you're young and I
and he had the bias of oh Alex knows you
So you you're getting special treatment
because Alex knows you you're the you're
the friend of the bosses right and so
he's like you got to do another one so
he had to do another one and then when
he got on the team what did he where did
he start low man low man on the totem he
was young and he had the bias of oh your
your boss is pet right he had to have
both of these biases against him because
nobody likes that guy right and I told
him that I said they're going to not
like you because you're young and
they're not going to like you because
they know you know me and I was like you
need to leave no [__] room for doubt
that you earned it I was like and so
you're going to be left of center you're
going to start 6 feet underground before
you can get your head over I was like
that's what it is and I was like either
you can [__] and moan about it and you
can lose and and be right and be right
about the fact that you're going to have
a bias against you or you can win win
anyways and
so what did he
do he became the top performing sales
rep with all the grown ass men and their
family
was there bias yes did he have to do
more to get on the team yes did he have
to prove himself in ways that no one
else had to
yes and so if you're in that position
and you feel like you have this bias
against you here's what I would ask if
you're an employee and this is what I
would encourage the business owners who
are listening to this ask this question
what would it take what would it take
for me to get on the team what would it
take for me to be the manager what would
it take for me to be the director What
would it take for me to get a raise what
would it take for me to get a promotion
if I'm the business owner trying to get
the deal what would it take for us to do
business together what would it take for
you to say yes what would I have to do
objectively I get that you've got some
you've got hesitation I understand that
I'm young I understand that I got in
here because I had some other guy who
tapped somebody else's shoulder and got
me an interview day one I get that I
understand that so what would it take
let me compensate let me not just tip
normal I'm not going to tip 20% because
other people who look like me don't tip
20 I was like I'll tip 100 just tell me
what would it take to change your
mind what would it take for me to not
look like a hick or for you to not think
that I'm completely illiterate or
uneducated what would it take no one
benefits from the excuse you hurt you
more by accepting that the excuse is
real because what the excuse of the of
saying that there is bias and that the
bias is the reason that you have not
moved forward is that it gives you an
excuse for not
succeeding that's all it does it gives
you a nice warm blink to say I'm not
winning but this is the reason why
because the alternative reason of saying
I'm just not good enough hurts your
ego and to be clear I not saying that
bias doesn't it absolutely exists but we
have to live in a world that it does
exist and win
anyways and so I'll show you I'll show
you a note that I Leave myself
because I I get in the same everybody
everybody's got [__] and so I'll show
you what the background on my phone is
right now this is the season I'm
in if you can see that it says just
win that's it it says just win two words
at the end of the day winners write
history and if you win in the end if you
become the top performing sales rep
that's all that matters and the only
people who care about the biases are the
ones who lose because those are the
those biases are the things that soften
their head when they when they put their
head down on their pillow at night
because it makes them feel okay it
doesn't hurt their ego as much to say
you know if I didn't have this bias I
would have won but no one remembers them
how much stronger of a story is it that
you win despite the bias you win despite
the disadvantage Oprah will always have
my eternal respect for being the first
female black billionaire who built a
media [__] Empire in the [__] 80s
no one else can do that and so that's
the thing is that the number of biases
that you have to act against you becomes
the more compelling story that no one
else who doesn't have those biases will
ever be able to
tell and if there's if there's anything
that gives me hope it's that is that you
get the opportunity you have this one
unique opportunity that you get to be an
example you get to be an inspiration to
other people who have red faces who have
green faces who are too young who are
too old because those B like I didn't
get hired for the tech job because I'm
too old you're not going to fix bias
because it's wishing that humans won't
learn and that's never going to happen
but you can still win by simply asking
what would it take and accepting the
only thing that you can control which is
that there is bias and the reason I did
not win is because I'm just not good
enough yet I'm just not undeniable
enough yet now I might be good enough if
I had a green face but I'm not good
enough if I have a red face so I got to
get that much [__]
better it's the only thing that you can
control
and so whether you're a business owner
and that restaurant that's on the wrong
side of the street if you have the best
pizza in the city people will go to the
hood where it's unsafe to get the pizza
everybody knows a restaurant where
you're like it's kind of on the wrong
side of town it's a little bit seedy but
man that Indian curry is [__] off the
hook everybody you know that spot now do
they have to be better than other places
that are in safer nicer parts of town
yes but it doesn't mean that it's
impossible it just means the bar is
higher and the only thing that we have
control over is whether we're willing to
make the [__]
climb and so I saw that post and I was
feeling spicy about it because the thing
is is like she was using that as the as
the Catalyst for her quitting her job to
start a start a business and I'm and I'm
all about that that's fine that's
awesome take take take take your life
into your own control but do not for a
second because I know that that belief
will not serve her her saying I didn't
get promoted because I was a woman
I didn't get respected because I was a
woman and believe me I know Lea doesn't
get nearly enough credit for all the
stuff she doesn't act if she was a guy
if she was just a dude and it was just
Alex and Dan and Dan was a 50-50 partner
of mine Dan would get shitload more
credit than Ila Lila's a woman and she's
my wife and so the bias that exists
against her is that how many business
guys have their wife they say she's the
CEO CEO and really she's just she's just
a secretary right she's just a help her
really just has some doing some admin
task so many people to this day we show
up to a business conference and other
business guys treat her like
that so what she GNA
do she's just got to be that much
[__] better and if you knew Lea which
many of you guys don't if you really
knew Lila she loves it she loves it
she's like we're gonna [__] murder
him lela's way more hardcore than I am
you guys just don't know that Lea's got
a [__] Dark Side you guys just don't
know which is great I love it I think
letting some of that dark side out and
and beating the [__] out of that victim
mentality that you have that because we
want to we want to lean into it we want
to we want to we it feels so much better
to say I didn't win because of outside
thing because it makes us feel better
I'm I'm good I'm good enough just but
there's this thing my restaurant is good
enough it's just on the wrong side of
the street right I really am good at
sales I'm just but you know they don't
give me the advancement because I knew
Alex or because I'm too young and I you
know I'll just wait a couple what would
it take what would it take for me to
become undeniable for me to be
bulletproof I want to have no chinks in
the armor nothing that anyone can hold
against me to say that I am not the best
for this thing and if there is a deal
that you need and there's a guy who who
like was beat the hell in high school
from guys who had flannel flannels and
he hates those people and I don't get
the deal guess what there's other people
that will give me the deal and you just
keep moving forward